what have you been growing this winter
in la cat
well a little too much kale
me thriving right now which is a little
sad but i've started sprouting a lot of
tomatoes indoors
and i started my pumpkins indoors this
year and i have brought my pumpkins here
my sprouts my sproutlings i am
so impressed hot well
it's tricky to know what to grow in the
winter so
joining us now from texas someone who's
gardening tick tocks
have inspired over 600
000 followers marcus bridgewater aka
garden marcus
marcus i just love how compelling and
cool at the same time your videos are
and i think
you're just going to bring a whole
generation um and turn them super green
and i was loving the fact that we were
in three geographical
places and how to speak to that because
what grows in l.a doesn't grow in texas
doesn't grow in new york
how do we garden for three different
areas
ah well there's a thing called zones and
zones are set up
geographically by region according to
climate
for plant growth and knowing that
the plants won't grow in every zone is
going to help you
keep your plants alive i myself have
killed a lot of plants in my day
unfortunately
those failures have led to
my success i don't think any expert
really got to where they
were without failing a ton of times and
i can tell you i've failed a ton
of times and i think that it's in those
failures
i've actually began to grow
i have to say i love hearing that
because
you know gardening is intimidating and
when somebody does come
out it with so much expertise they just
think oh there's all these things i
don't know i can't even
know where to begin i see that happening
all the time and i tell people
lesson versus barrier learn lessons
instead of creating barriers it's going
to take you
a long way and the more lessons you
learn the more peace you have
is this about gardening still marcus
because
i am feeling like that's a life lesson
uh i think that the garden is filled
with life lessons i
have had so many reassured um kat
i mean she's in la what do you think of
what she's growing in her beautiful
little boxes oh my gosh they
are so beautiful so beautiful
these are called cinderella pumpkins
what else could cat approach in the
winter
or inside right now it being in los
angeles
for beginner gardeners i usually tell
them to start with
seedlings or more mature plants but
seeing is how a cat is so far
along in her journey i can i'm sure she
can handle
growing more seeds so the seeds i would
start with now
and prepare to transplant in march are
cucumber cantaloupes
zucchini watermelon and sweet potatoes
and you can eat the uh you can eat the
green and the leaves from sweet potatoes
right absolutely um you can make it into
tea
as well um a lot of those things are
edible
wow didn't know that amazing um
let's talk about you're in texas that's
a different zone what's good to grow
inside right now
uh inside you want to go watermelons
sweet peppers or swiss chard
but i am growing some
dragon fruit and i am also growing
a propagation of a
trumpet plant now a propagation is when
you take
a cutling from a plant it's either a
stem
or a leaf and you create a whole new
plant
so a month ago this
trumpet plant was only the stem
all of these leaves and all of these
roots
are new growth from this past month
how exciting oh my this really gets me
going i'm gonna be honest
i agree well speaking of what can i grow
here in new york
inside right now well in new york city
you can grow
basil cabbage broccoli and cauliflower
but don't worry if you're a beginner
gardener and you're worried about seeds
you can go
philodendron snake plants zz plants
and some of my favorite
pothos you can grow those indoors
year round i love like how the leaves
are heart shaped too
okay so basically um if you go to the
drewberrymore show.com
we're gonna have marcus's list for the
zones and what you can grow
inside right now considering that it's
still winter
marcus will you come back in spring
and we can do a spring edition of this
trio and talk about the garden of life
oh fantastic thank you awesome that'd be
fantastic
oh thank you marcus i really do think
that you're bringing
accessibility and like straight up
coolness
as well as all of your incredible
information to the gardening world and
inspiring a whole new
generation of people and i thank you so
much for doing that
and we'll see you in spring awesome
thank you so much for having me
and i'll see you in spring thank you
marcus so
much
cat
i mean i can't wait to see you in the
spring and just like
be together in our separate gardens um
okay kat
jennings i just we're gonna plan
a future date on this show in our
gardens
with our cats it's all in process and
also
i just can't be more excited for one
division the show that
everybody is losing their minds for
right now
and you are at the center of being
the conductor for all of us and you're
so
special and it's streaming right now on
disney plus obviously and we'll be
hanging on every episode as it comes out
and uh i'll see you so soon
[Music]
you